hey what is up guys my name is a journo
and I just wanted to make a quick video
discussing a lot of dare
um Okay so yesterday I made a video
saying that I was gonna stop YouTube for
about three months and finish school
um but I also said that
you know if you didn't watch the whole
video I also said that I would be uh
doing Madame dare this weekend A lot of
them did 24 a lot of them I guess he
pronounce it actually because it is
Latin for to give a game I think that's
what it is
um
so that's what that's what it means uh
but basically for those of you who don't
know it's a 48 hour game development
slash programming competition in which
you have 48 hours to make a game based
on obscure fame
um it's very challenging uh experience
I've never done it before actually so I
don't know if it's challenging or not I
would imagine it would be though because
making a game from scratch in 48 hours
is is hard
um it's very hard because you have to
finish that game it's not just making an
engine in 48 hours that would be easy
it's making a game in 48 hours it's fun
to play
so yeah that's gonna be hard but um I
will be doing it and I will be live
streaming the entire event
right here to YouTube to my YouTube
channel alright so what's gonna happen
is because it's 48 hours long
um it starts okay yeah this is the other
thing that I wanted to mention before I
uh uh get on with this real quick uh if
you go to what is it like the
timezoneconverter.com I remember I found
a good website
let's answer this one
um
yes yeah okay so basically what you can
do is you can enter
the time when it will start and it will
convert it into your time zone so it
starts at 1am
so just put zero one I don't know zero
one
um and that will be GMT
uh and then you can enter where you are
for example I'm in Melbourne and it'll
give you the time so it'll start at 11AM
it starts at 1am GMT on Saturday the
25th of August so in three days
it's Saturday 25th yeah
um so that'll be 11 A.M so so what you
can do is you can type this in
um and then you can type whatever you
ask or whether that be I don't know
whoops
whether that be uh give me this thing I
want to type here
whether that be
whether that be Germany for example so
you can type that in and it'll give you
the time which is you know 3am or like
I don't know La 6PM you know the
previous day so Friday the 24th
um it'll give you the time this is uh
it'll give you the time wherever you may
be so that way you know exactly where
the stream will start and the stream
will actually start at uh hang on at um
30 so the stream will start I'll start
the stream half an hour before the event
so that I can um I can get organized and
maybe answer a few questions and get
ready get my mind into uh into that so
that's when it will start okay that's
that is where my live stream will begin
now the logistics of this because
because it is a 48 hour stream I'm not
going to actually be streaming for 48
hours okay first of all I'm not going to
stay awake for 48 hours there is no way
that it's happening
um I will indeed go to sleep
uh for I don't know maybe I'll sleep
like six to six hours a night I I do I
don't want to sleep like four hours or
two three hours a night because um my
productivity will be ridiculously like
it'll be diminished like it's not going
to be worth it because I'll be I'll just
I won't be able to like code or think
the next day so um yeah and be and when
I when I will be absent for like I don't
know eight hours maybe
um I will actually shut the stream down
because there's absolutely no point
having a 48 hour long YouTube video that
you guys will struggle to load and play
through so what I will do is I will stop
and start the stream constantly every
time I go away for more than one hour
I'll probably stop the stream so you
guys might be thinking all right well
what if I want to share the story more
you know put share the link on Facebook
the link will always change won't it
yeah it will because they are separate
streams technically and
because of that what you can do is you
can actually go to my channel
let me just shut myself up by hitting
the pause button you can actually go to
my channel right and what will happen is
the active stream will always be the
first thing you see on my channel so
what I'll actually do
for the Stream
is I will actually change it into live
broadcaster
um like the live broadcaster template
which um
which I don't I won't show anything here
but what will happen is actually let me
let me see what it'll look like
yeah nothing yet um when I am live
though it will be black I believe and
um what you'll be able to see is
actually
um the live stream here and like the the
comment the comment like window yes you
can like type live comments and
everything and um yeah so that'll be
that'll be like the main thing so what
happens is you can just give youtube.com
forward slash the Cherno project that
will be the link and that will that will
be the permanent link okay that will be
the permalink that will always say the
same so that will be the link of the
live stream all right when it starts let
me just change back to
whatever I had before uh
Creator think of that
uh I think it was a blogger
yeah he has a lot of okay
finish anything
um yeah so that's what that's what's
gonna happen Okay
um it will just be it'll just be on my
channel you can once once you'll see the
live stream here you can actually click
on the name and you'll be taken to the
official like watch page okay so that'll
be that'll be fine
um if you want to watch it like that you
can uh
the other thing is I did actually make
another blog post I made a website in
case you didn't catch yesterday's video
called the channel.com and um
um I'm just gonna keep blogging there
whenever I can because it's here then
making a YouTube video because I will be
busy again for the next three months so
um so what I did is I I did actually
make a post
um about a lot of and as you can see I
wrote up quite a bit so what you can do
is you can actually read that and
that'll just be at the channel.com in
fact the actual post
URL is I'll put in the in the
description but um you can actually you
can actually create and create a new
account as well on my website and you'll
be able to
um post comments you can post comments
anyway you just gotta fill everything
out instead of just posting the comment
but um yeah that'll that'll sort of
that'll sort of describe you know what I
want to use to make the game I'll be
using Java obviously and I'll make it
from scratch just using pure Java no
libraries
um at all
um so otherwise I'll make my own engine
from scratch called the Cherno engine
1.0
um I don't know what it's called yet but
um yeah I will I will I will I will make
it from scratch so don't worry about
that and um
but anyway all the other things that
I'll use other ideas I've got for games
perhaps what kind of game I'm going to
make that's all in the blog post so just
go ahead follow the link in the in the
description and you will see
um and yeah I'll put the time zone
converter thing in the description as
well so you know exactly when it starts
but yeah the official time and date is
1am GMT
um
uh on the set on Saturday the 25th of
August so I guess I'll see you guys then
because I'm not going to put up any
content until then and um yeah you know
feel free to share that with all of your
friends as well
um because I think I think it's going to
be a great experience and a great event
so yeah I hope to see you all there
actually all like 2 600 of you there
because that'll be that'll be suede so
we can actually uh have a bit of a party
and I can make a game in 48 hours and
you guys can uh can watch Me Maybe maybe
you guys will learn a lot as well
because
um oh one more thing actually before I
go is
um I don't I'm not sure how much I'm
don't don't think it's going to be like
a massive tutorial it's because there's
no way that I can actually afford to
still remain efficient while explaining
all the code but what I will try and do
is roughly explain like what I'm trying
to do with this code so as I type it I
might say a few things but I'm not going
to go back and rephrase things and
actually explain it properly because I
can't one thing I do hope to do maybe
and this is maybe after my exams in in
November is maybe go over the live
stream and like commentate it and be
like yeah this is why I'm doing this and
you know what I mean like do do a nice
like commentary audio commentary on it
after you know after it's done not live
though so um yeah anyway I hope to see
you all there and I'll see you guys on
Saturday bye